bombs mailed to prominent democratic
figures megan kelly gets into hot water
for her comments on halloween
and president trump comes under fire for
saying he's a nationalist we'll get into
all of it i'm ben shapiro this is the
ben shapiro show
[Music]
man things are getting quite ugly out
there and we're going to get
into why that is and what we can do to
actually stop this
why it is that we are not only why we're
polarized but what we can do to sort of
take the temperature down a little bit
because it seems like that's something
we need to do especially in the run-up
to this election first let's talk about
those trips you've been taking to the
post office i know you run a business
and that means that you have to take
all your stuff to the post office and
then you have to mail it that's time
consuming the post office is a wonderful
place with great services but why do you
want to spend that time in the car or
online instead
you should just do it straight from your
desk at stamps.com with stamps.com you
can get all the amazing services of the
post office
directly from your desk 24 7 when it's
convenient for you buy and print
official us postage for any letter any
package
using your own computer and printer the
mail carrier picks it up you just click
print mail and you're done we use it
here at the daily wire offices it saves
us time and it saves us money
i use it at my house as well you can use
it there too and one of the beautiful
things about this is
again you don't have to wait for the
post office to open for you to actually
print out the postage print it directly
onto the envelope onto a sticker
directly onto the onto a piece of paper
and then tape it to the
the piece of mail it's very easy to do
and it's going to take you a lot less
time and it'll save you money too
right now if you use promo code shapiro
you get a special offer 55 bucks a free
postage a digital scale and a four week
trial all you have to do is go to
stamps.com and before you do anything
else
click on that radio microphone at the
top of the homepage and type in promo
code shapiro that's stum
that's stamps.com enter promo code
shapiro go check it out
right now okay so the breaking news
today
is this really really awful news that
explosive divisives have now been
found addressed to hillary clinton and
barack obama this after yesterday
there's a story about an explosive
device sent to the home
of george soros the major leftist donor
all of this of course is abysmal
disgusting horrific whoever is doing
this should be arrested
they should be tried and they should go
to jail for the rest of their lives this
is
this is just an awful awful thing and
what's amazing is that if you say that
publicly there's a group of people who
immediately suggest that it's a false
flag attack
or that depending on the target of these
sorts of bombs that it's okay
which suggests to me that there is a
collective a sort of collective
mental illness that's fallen across a
small but but significant group of
people
who believe that the other side is so
evil that everything
up to and including sending pipe bombs
in the mail to them is justified which
is just
sick that means that we have a sickness
in our society that needs to be
eradicated a mental sickness in our
society that needs to be eradicated
here's the story from abc news explosive
devices addressed to hillary clinton's
home
when the house of former president
barack obama were intercepted the time
warner center that is home to cnn in new
york city was evacuated
after a suspicious package that
apparently looks like a pipe bomb was
sent there a suspicious package was also
received at the new york city office
of governor andrew cuomo sources told
abc news
which should narrow it down a little bit
it sounds like this is probably somebody
from new york state if they're sending
it to
andrew cuomo as opposed to say governor
jerry brown in california
investigators are working to determine
whether the two devices addressed to
clinton and obama are connected to a
pipe bomb found earlier this week in the
home of mailbox
of billionaire george soros near where
the clintons live in chappaqua
new york the preliminary belief is that
all three devices are of similar pipe
bomb style construction
now the immediate jump by folks on the
left was to suggest
that this was a right winger who hates
left wingers and has been inspired by
president trump
as i have said for years now i despise
when people blame individual acts of
violence or attempted violence on
generalized political rhetoric
unless you are actively calling for
violence and someone takes you up on
that offer
you are not responsible for the violent
actions of people
who take you to the ultimate extreme
in terms of violence so for example when
a bernie sanders supporter went and shot
up a congressional baseball game
and nearly killed the house majority
whip and the media covered it for all of
15 minutes
i didn't blame bernie sanders because
that wasn't bernie sanders fault
when a when a kind of fringe member of
black lives matter shot up police
officers in dallas a couple of years ago
right after barack obama had made
speeches condemning police officers is
broadly racist
i didn't say that that was barack
obama's fault it wasn't barack obama's
fault it was an act of evil on the part
of a person
who was actually evil or mentally ill or
both
and that had nothing to do with barack
obama's words
i think that you can raise the
temperature in society
and do serious damage to the society
because you have raised the temperature
of that society
but i'm not going to attribute
individual acts of violence and evil
to individual political viewpoints
unless those viewpoints are actively
calling for violence and to do anything
less
leads to the sort of censorship that
makes the country a worse place in that
way
if you believe that free speech is
inherently connected to violence you are
more likely to crack down on free speech
in order to prevent that violence
and that seems to be more of a broad
danger than individuals in the united
states who do evil things
so with that said obviously this is
really really bad stuff
and it goes to the question of motives
because
what we are seeing now why is this
breaking out so much why
are we seeing ricin sent to susan
collins
in maine why are we seeing rocks thrown
thrown through the windows of kevin
mccarthy's offices in california
why are we seeing bombs put in george
soros's mailbox
it's because they're a group of people
who have been fully convinced that the
other side
and i don't just mean the other side
ideas i mean people who are on the other
side are actively
members of evil they're hilarious
figures
you know that sort of rhetoric is is
responsible for heating
up the temperature it's not responsible
for individual acts of violence but it
is responsible
for an increase in the temperature and
the more you increase the temperature
the more you can expect that there are
going to be people
who are going to go to the ultimate
extreme of attempting to engage in
violence you've seen it on the left
you've seen it some on the right
and it's really ugly no matter how you
slice it it seems to me
that a lot of this is springing from
a basic failure of values and the basic
failure of values is something that
we call in hebrew there's a there's a
hebrew commandment that you are supposed
to consider everybody in their best
possible life the hebrew phrase word is
which literally means that you're
supposed to think of everybody's merits
we don't do that anymore we tend to
instead think of everybody's demerits we
tend to think of the worst form of
everybody's arguments we tend to think
of the worst motives
on the part of people with whom we
disagree we see someone say something
and the first thing we think is not okay
what's the reasonable explanation
for what they're saying or what maybe
were they thinking instead we
immediately jumped to
this person is the worst person in the
world and their rhetoric is obviously
intended for in for the worst possible
effect now
i can't say i've been innocent in this
because i don't think anybody in
politics is innocent in this
but i do think that we're going to have
to start trying to attribute to
people perhaps a less a less
vicious motive than we have been
attributing to them so far because
people hate each other not because of
what they do but because of what they
think
they are they think the other person is
thinking that's where we are in american
society
it's one thing to hate another person
because of something that they do
right they somebody murders your father
you're allowed to hate them
but what we have come to in society is
actions that can be interpreted in a
couple of ways and we have decided to
interpret them in the least flattering
most nasty way about somebody else so to
take an example
there's a religious baker in colorado he
says listen i don't want to bake a cage
for cake for a same-sex wedding because
i believe
that homosexuality is sinful we
immediately attribute that to malice
we immediately attribute that to that's
because the baker is a mean man who
hates gay people
never mind that the baker's been serving
gay couples for years in his
establishment
and he's just saying i don't want to be
roped or hamstrung into violating my own
religious precepts
no we have to attribute to him hatred we
have to attribute to him viciousness
and we see this on the other side as
well there are folks on the left who
will say things like
well i want nationalized health care and
instead of us saying
on the right well maybe they want
nationalized health care because
they don't understand the issue or
because they
misunderstand how nationalized
healthcare works or because they have a
good faith argument about how we should
redistribute resources
instead we go to it's because they want
control it's because they want control
once you start explaining people's
motives without reference to their
actual behavior
you're going to get yourself into hot
water politically and you're going to
divide the country on a more
significant and long-lasting level and
yet this is also here's the problem
this is also the stuff that wins the
elections the stuff that wins your
elections in today's society
is castigating your opponent as morally
somehow
deficient saying that your opponent is
not just wrong but evil
you know ronald reagan was famous for
saying that
it isn't that democrats are are just
uh are evil it's that they know so much
that isn't so in other words he
attributed to ignorance
what he could not attribute to malice
and it's it's
it's a rule that i've had on the program
try to attribute to stupidity what you
can't attribute to malice
but when it comes to political fights
the easiest thing to do
is attribute malice to the other side
and you're seeing this manifest in a
couple of different ways let's take for
example
the way that the left has decided to
read president trump's comments about
nationalism so the president of the
united states gave a speech a couple of
days ago
in which he was talking about illegal
immigration and president trump is no
stranger to character attacks he uses
them on a fairly frequent basis against
his political opponents
whether they're former opponents like
ted cruz or whether they are opponents
in the democratic party why because it's
effective
it's a lot more effective to attack
somebody's character than to attack
their ideas
because we tend to vote based on whether
we think somebody is a good person or
not
not based on whether we believe their
ideas are good see evaluating ideas
takes time
and effort evaluating ideas requires you
to actually sit there and determine
whether you think that the evidence is
there to support a particular idea but
evaluating a human being you can do like
that
and science tends to show that that's
exactly how we deal with other human
beings in our daily life and in politics
more broadly
when you meet somebody you tend to make
a judgment about that person within the
first five seconds of meeting them
whether you think this is a good person
or a bad person a nice person or a mean
person
a person who you think is going to
benefit your life or a person who's
gonna be a detriment to your life you
make that decision in seconds that's a
lot easier
and a lot more instinctive the human
brain is built for that rather than
thinking through okay what are the
policies that this politician is
suggesting
we as a society need to start thinking
about the policies a lot more and stop
attributing motives so much
but again it is easier and more
electorally lucrative to suggest evil
motive
on the part of people that you face down
character attacks are deeply effective i
wrote an entire book about this in 2013
called bullies
and the entire premise of the book was
that basically the left had decided to
leave
idea arguments outside the realm of the
norm
and instead have decided to attack on a
character basis everybody on the right
so the latest example here's president
trump a couple of days ago
saying that he's a nationalist not a
globalist now even implicit in this
comment by president trump
is a character attack on the left the
character attack on the left is that
people in the united states who disagree
with him about immigration
actually don't care about the united
states right that's sort of implicit in
what president trump is saying
but the real point that he's making is
that his priorities
are the protection of the american
people above all
else and other priorities such as for
example
kindness or human rights those take
second priority to protection of the
nation's borders
maybe for human rights reasons maybe for
charitable reasons but that's the way he
thinks of things
we're going to see in a second what
president trump said and also
how the democrats responded because they
didn't respond by making a critique of
president trump's ideas or what he was
saying
instead they basically suggested the
worst form of president trump president
trump
wasn't spouting an idea president trump
is only saying this stuff because
president trump is a big meanie a
terrible terrible person
again this is not unique to one side of
the aisle it's just the most convenient
example
today and we'll get to a couple other
examples of it too in just a second
first
let's talk about improving your business
you know what's not smart job sites that
overwhelm you with tons of the wrong
resumes you know what is smart
ziprecruiter.com
dailywire unlike other job sites
ziprecruiter doesn't wait for candidates
to find you
ziprecruiter finds them for you it's
powerful matching technology scans
thousands of resumes it identifies
people with the right skills education
and experience for your job and then
actively invites them to apply to get
qualified candidates fast there's no
more sorting through the wrong resumes
no more waiting for the right candidates
to apply
zip recruiter is rated the number one
employment seeking site by employers in
the united states that comes from
hiring sites on trust pilot with over a
thousand reviews right now
my listeners can get a special deal you
can try zip recruiter for free at
ziprecruiter.com
dailywire at ziprecruiter.com daily wire
again ziprecruiter.com
dailywire zip recruiter is indeed the
smartest way to hire
if we decide that employees at this
company
say for example young employees who
don't know old songs and thus make
everyone feel incredibly old at this
company
let's say that we decide you know what
we've had enough of them we decided to
replace them zip recruiter is what we'll
use ziprecruiter.com
dailywire no that wasn't a passive a
passive aggressive reference to colton
haas our young reporter who didn't know
the song no scrubs it wasn't that at all
ziprecruiter.com dailywire to try it for
free
zip recruiter is indeed the smartest way
to hire okay so
here's president trump talking about
nationalism and then we'll look at the
democratic response
because this is driving up the
temperature again it's not unique to one
side i keep repeating that because i
think it's important
i think it's important especially in
light of the fact that somebody
obviously sending bombs to democrats
okay
democrats have been engaged in mob
violence and now some crazy person
or evil person or both is sending bombs
to democrats in the mail so obviously
the temperature has risen on both sides
and by the way there are studies that
show this
there's a chart i talked about on this
program i think a couple of weeks ago
when we were in when we were in memphis
that showed the level of hatred within
each party for the other party has been
rising consistently for years but it has
skyrocketed among republicans
and in any case here's president trump
talking about nationalism then you're
going to see the sort of
failure of that jewish principle i was
talking about don mccaff's
the the idea of trying to think of
people in the best possible light you're
going to see how democrats respond that
violates that precept here's president
trump
a globalist is a person
that wants the globe to do well frankly
not caring about our country so much
and you know what we can't have that you
know they have a word
it sort of became old-fashioned it's
called a nationalist
and i say really we're not supposed to
use that word you know what i am
i'm a nationalist okay i'm a national
okay so you can hear
the the sort of implicit character
attack president trump is you know
leveling at folks on the left there
but he is not actually saying something
racist he's not saying something sexist
or bigoted here he's saying
that some people have a priority which
is to uplift
places in the world that are not the
united states that's not my priority now
you can say
that president trump is straw manning
his opposition i think that's a fair
critique
you can say that president trump is
maligning his opposition in an
unfair way fair but that's not how
democrats reacted
the way democrats reacted was by
doubling down on the lining
so they say that when president trump
says nationalist what he really means
is that he is a racist so here is joe
biden remember joe biden
that guy who's at john mccain's funeral
calling for a new better politics
joe biden the guy who said that john
mccain and i we got along we were best
friends because
we never questioned one another's
motives here is joe biden at a rally
last night suggesting that donald trump
is like george wallace
an actual segregationist who by the way
was a democrat and therefore is probably
closer to joe biden than donald trump
in any case here is joe biden saying
that trump is like george wallace thanks
to the nationalism comments
no president has ever led by fear
not lincoln not roosevelt not kennedy
not reagan
this president is more like george
wallace than george washington
okay i mean that is about as vile
statement you can make about another
human being as is possible
and there's a guy who says that he wants
a new kind of politics and then he
maligns the president
of the united states as george wallace
an active segregationist
it's an amazing statement but again not
unexpected from joe biden a man who
suggested that mitt romney
mitt romney the most milk-toast
candidate in american history
wanted to put black people back in
chains during the 2012 campaign
these sort of character attacks have
been happening since long before trump
and they continue unabated on the part
of people on both sides but
the left really has ramped it up there's
no question the left is ramped up i
think the right has ramped it up in
reactionary response
here's more evidence of that so maisie
hirono senator from hawaii
when president trump says that he's a
nationalist she says maybe it's because
he's a white supremacist or an
anti-semite
we should stop giving him the benefit of
the doubt that he doesn't understand
what he means when he
refers to nationalists or any of these
other terms
these are not just dog whistles but it's
bull horns it's racism
it's basically for many people it's
anti-semitic it's white supremacy he
knows very well what he's talking about
even if he professes otherwise okay
maisie my antenna is
pretty high up there for for
anti-semitism when the president says
nationalism
i'm not hearing nazi okay when the
president says nationalism that is not
what he is saying
he is saying that he prioritizes the
united states border security
over the human rights of people trying
to make their way across that board you
may disagree with that
but there is no way that that has
anything to do with racism or
anti-semitism but this became
the actual talking point across the left
yesterday
jim acosta of cnn and ladies find you
somebody who loves you
like jim acosta loves him some jim
acosta here is jim acosta saying
well maybe when president trump says
nationalist he means white nationalist
okay or maybe when jim acosta says stuff
i just think that he's an idiot here's
jim acosta
when you're demonizing middle easterners
and making the suggestion that they're
they're terrorists and so on in that
caravan without offering any proof
and then calling yourself a nationalist
in front of thousands and thousands of
people
i don't think it's a stretch for a lot
of americans out there to wonder whether
or not the president is
secretly considering himself a white
nationalist so
much journalism so much objective
journalism
there from jim acosta i don't think it's
any wonder that people ask whether the
president is a nazi when he's saying
when he says things like we should
protect our border and nationalism
i mean flashback to barack obama 2005
saying exactly the same thing
barack obama actually said this right
here's obama circa 2005 when he was just
a senator barely a glint in the nation's
eye here he was saying exactly the same
thing as donald trump
they are a generous and welcoming people
here in the united states but those who
enter the country illegally and those
who employ them disrespect
the rule of law and they are
showing disregard for those who are
following the law
we simply cannot allow people to pour
into the united states
undetected undocumented unchecked
and circumventing the line of people who
are waiting patiently
diligently and lawfully uh to become
immigrants
in this country okay so uh you know
again
that i guess that barack obama way back
when was a sort of white nationalist
also you know being half white
i guess that he was a white nationalist
as well it wasn't just jim acosta who
at this point basically everything that
he says should be prefaced with dear
diary
because he says all of the quiet stuff
out loud it was also nbc news's peter
alexander more objective journalism from
the mainstream media
on the issue of nationalism yeah it
definitely does i mean undertones that
are not just racial they're
xenophobic this is something that the
president and sort of shied away from
in the past obviously nationalism was a
phrase that steve bannon
uh obviously embraced over the course of
the campaign and a lot of the
president's opponents
tried to pin this idea on him now listen
i'm somebody who has said that i prefer
patriotism to nationalism i don't think
that nationalism alone is enough i think
there are ties that bind us
ties of history ties of culture but what
actually makes the united states the
united states is the root idea
embedded in the declaration of
independence and the constitution and
backed by two thousand years
of judeo-christian history or rather
three thousand years of judeo-christian
history
and that's what makes the united states
the united states is the idea of
classical liberalism
combined with cultural conservatism and
that's what makes the united states
unique
that is a unique idea in world history
so i'm not such a big fan even
of the president using nationalistic
language but to suggest that that is
white supremacy is just idiocy
but again this comes back to the basic
idea you want to raise the temperature
in a country
you want to raise the the hackles of
people on the other side
all you have to do is just question
motives day in and day out and that's
what we are now in the business of doing
and again i want to work on this myself
you know every time i give
uh some sort of you know values advice i
try to think about how often i violate
those values i would imagine i do it
fairly often
i want to work on it myself i think we
all should work on it because
the truth is that in a country where we
agree on 90
of our values we really do i think in
the end agree on 90
of our values the only way you can
divide us is by
castigating people who disagree with you
on the manifestation of those values
as evil nasty bigoted horrible people
by the way this is how you got trump on
the left i mean you want to know how you
got trump this haggadrome by castigating
folks in the middle of the country as
deplorable
bitter clingers for 10 years and then
they said you know what screw you
we don't like you either that's how you
got this situation that's
pretty much american politics in a
nutshell i'm going to show you another
example of that
that came out of a weird place yesterday
megan kelly got herself into hot water
over on nbc and i think there are some
illustrative lessons to be learned there
but first let's talk about your second
amendment right so the second amendment
is obviously designed in order to
protect those key rights in the bill of
rights and like many of you i am a gun
owner depending on the state you live in
in the concealed carry laws
maybe you want to protect your family
when you go up maybe you don't live in a
crappy state like california
and you actually have the capacity to
concealed carry well that's why you're
going to need a great holster to
properly hold your gun
and your law-abiding citizen you want to
keep your fellow citizens safe concealed
carry is a wonderful thing
g-code creates hand-crafted holstered
made right here in the united states not
just run-of-the-mill pre-packaged molded
holsters
we're talking about holsters that are
made by military veterans
meticulous about quality innovation and
worksmanship
every holster g-code makes is quality
checked at four different stages of the
process
they are test fitted with an actual
firearm to ensure proper fit and
function not just made
getting something that was made in a
foreign country off a production line
this stuff was made by military vets
okay the owners of g-code are military
veterans
they're committed to excellence in
everything they do and it's the only
holster you're ever going to want
whether you're military law enforcement
or a civilian
g-code has a holster just right for you
every g-code product is designed for
real-world use
no fluff no hype just great performance
learn more order online at range5.com
that's rangethenumber5.comrange5.com and
use promo code ben
for 15 off go check it out right now use
promo code ben
for 15 off alrighty so
there's a big controversy that broke out
yesterday over over megan kelly
now full disclosure i'm friends with
megan kelly i think that megyn kelly is
a really nice lady
uh i've i was i used to be a regular
guest on her fox news show when she was
on fox news
and i wish her nothing but the best
megan got herself into hot water because
she was on yesterday on nbc news and
they were doing soft stuff and what was
the soft stuff they were doing
it was it was the nbc morning show well
the soft stuff that they were doing
was they were talking about halloween
costumes well this always gets into
dicey areas because as soon as you start
talking about
limits on halloween costumes and what
should be allowed and what shouldn't be
allowed people get very easily offended
by halloween costumes
to the point where people on the left
have been suggesting in recent years
that white girls shouldn't be able to
dress up as moana for halloween
we talked about it last halloween it's
just idiocy it's just idiocy
my daughter is going to dress up as any
disney princess she chooses but
megan steps into some pretty frau
territory here because she's talking
about the use
of of dressing up as black folks for
halloween
and whether you can put on black makeup
to dress up as a black person for
halloween here's what megan has to say
and this goes to
the central contention i'm making today
which is that people are jumping
to the worst possible conclusion about
people's motives without actually
analyzing what the motives are so here
is megan talking about
halloween costumes involving putting on
black makeup or darkening your skin for
a costume
and the blowback was just enormous
but what is racist because because truly
you do get in trouble if you are a white
person who puts on black face on
halloween or a black person who puts on
white face for halloween like when i was
a kid that was okay as long as you were
dressing up as like a character
okay so she got in all sorts of trouble
because she said when i was a kid it was
okay to dress up as like diana ross the
guy's a big diana ross fan
in my neighborhood if somebody darkened
their skin to look like diana ross
because if you just put on a fright wig
uh you know to look like diana ross
people still didn't know who you were so
you darkened your skin or whatever so
people went nuts over this this is megyn
kelly being ignorant
and bigoted and racist and so megyn
kelly actually had to issue an apology
here's what she said
dear friends and teammates one of the
wonderful things about my job is that i
get the chance to express and hear a lot
of opinions
today is one of those days where
listening carefully to other points of
view including from friends and
colleagues is leading me to rethink my
own views
when we had the roundtable discussion
earlier today about the controversy of
making your face look like a different
race as part of a halloween costume
i suggested that this seemed okay if
done as part of this holiday where
people have the chance to make
themselves look like others the iconic
diana ross came up as an example
to me i thought why would it be
controversial for someone dressing up as
diana ross
to make herself look like this amazing
woman as a way of honoring and
respecting her
i realize now that such behavior is
indeed wrong and i am sorry the history
of blackface in our culture is abhorrent
the wound's too deep
i've never been a pc kind of person but
i understand that we do need to be more
sensitive in this day and age
particularly on race and ethnicity
issues which far from being healed have
been exacerbated in our politics over
the past year
this is a time for more understanding
love sensitivity and honor and i want to
be part of that i look forward to
continuing that discussion
i'm honored to work with all of you
every day megan so
i think that her apology is perfectly
appropriate by the way but the outsized
reactions who original comments is
pretty astonishing so here was kirsten
powers
who supposedly is in favor of people
saying what they want freedom of speech
here's what she tweeted
dear white people who are upset that you
can't dress up as another race or
culture for halloween
your feelings don't matter the only
feelings that matter are those
who feel disrespected or mocked by you
appropriating their culture for
entertainment
show some common decency so basically
the feelings of people who are non-white
matter more than the people the feelings
of people who are white
now i think that there is some actual
nuance to this issue here is the nuance
to this issue
blackface has a long terrible history in
the united states
okay people actually dressing up as
black folks in order to mock them
was something that happened on a
frequent basis all the way up till the
1950s and 1960s in the united states
and you can go back and you can watch
old videos on youtube of people
dressing up doing putting making their
faces black and giving themselves big
lips in
really really racist fashion and then
singing mammy songs in order to mock
black folks
and it's very much the same thing as in
in anti-semitic cultures for centuries
where people would put on a hook
nose and they'd and they'd put on a fake
belly and
curly side locks and then they would
suggest that they were jewish right i
mean
it's the same sort of thing like
dressing up as a culture to mock that
culture
is disgusting unacceptable actually
racist
now is that what megan kelly was
suggesting this is where we get into the
issue
of assuming people's motives here's my
opinion on people
darkening their face for costumes like
this
i agree that it's inappropriate
specifically because of the past and i
think that it is fair for people to look
at
this sort of thing and be sensitive
about it but i think it would also be
worthwhile to recognize there is a
difference
between being ignorant slash racially
insensitive and being racist
nowhere was megan kelly suggesting that
black people should be mocked
black people are inferior in any way
in fact what megyn kelly was suggesting
is that maybe white people want to dress
up as some famous black people because
they admire those famous black people
that is not the same thing as people
dressing up in blackface now again that
doesn't mean
that it's okay to go to a frat party
dressed as a black person with
black makeup on right that's insensitive
and you should
take into account black people's
feelings about historic
use of this sort of costuming for
mockery
but i also think there's a difference
between even a frat boy going to a party
and a little girl who decides that she
wants to dress up as michelle obama and
so she puts on dark makeup
because i think that you can pretty
easily tell the difference in motives
the attempt to misattribute motives in
our society is really gross
megan kelly is not a racist and megyn
kelly was not attempting to be racist by
that statement
at best you know at worst at worst megan
kelly was being ignorant of the history
of blackface and the impact it still has
on black folks in the united states
that's at worst
okay but there is no way that megyn
kelly was actually suggesting it's okay
to mock black people that is not what
was happening here and yet
here is cnn's don lemon suggesting that
megyn kelly actually
is a racist because there's never been a
time when blackface was acceptable first
of all he doesn't know
where she lived he doesn't know what
kind of parties she went to like don
lemon doesn't know that
so if his suggestion is that megan kelly
was a racist when she was seven years
old because she dressed up as diana ross
and blackened her face for it
i would suggest that don lemon doesn't
really know what he's talking about
he may know what he's talking about
historically with regard to blackface
but
again there's a difference between
darkening your face for a costume to
praise an african-american person and
darkening your face to mock
african-american people
and again i've said several times in
this segment i still don't think that
you should do it to
praise african-american people
specifically because there are too many
black folks who are going to look at
that and say well maybe you're mocking
me maybe the real reason you're doing
that is because you're mocking me so out
of sensitivity you shouldn't do that
but the attempt to immediately
attribute the worst available motive to
megyn kelly is really telling and it
says something about the nastiness of
our politics right now
megan is 47 years old she's our age
there has never been a time
in that in her 47 years that blackface
has been acceptable
um there were all white people on that
panel there were no african-americans no
people of color there to say
hey megan not cool
okay so this is this is really
really absurd you know again the it's
it's the
taking blackface seriously is fine but
misattributing motives is not i'll give
you an example you want you know
you want to know how we should deal with
these issues really how we should deal
with these issues the same way that
jamie foxx deals with these issues so
jamie foxx
was you know is is obviously an
incredibly prominent black man
in the united states has made lots of
money as a musician as an actor
very talented guy he's very close
friends with robert downey jr
a few years ago he did a podcast with
joe rogan and in the middle of this
podcast
the question of robert downey jr
actually putting on blackface
for the movie tropic thunder came up
robert downey jr was nominated for a
best supporting actor oscar there is no
way by the way
that even i think when was tropic
thunder made maybe 10 years ago
eight years ago maybe eight years ago in
any case there is no way that movie gets
made even today
because of the great sensitivity around
identity politics but here is
jamie foxx's perfectly decent
explanation of robert downey jr and how
he feels about all of this
people have to understand where it comes
from there are real people out there
that really mean you harm
like outside of us i mean there's some
real people who really don't like you
whatever you are whether you're black
you're white you're straight you're gay
whatever it is there's some people who
really don't like
we're the entertainment and it's easy
we're easy targets
okay so when when jamie foxx suggests
you have to know where it's coming from
there are some people who are bad out
there who don't like you but robert
downey jr is not one of those people
why don't we start thinking of each
other as people who probably could be
friends if we would stop treating each
other like garbage
okay megan kelly is not going to a party
dressed in blackface to mock black
people
and it is kind of amazing how certain
people get away with this sort of stuff
because
everybody assumes the best motives on
their part so for example
tom hanks in 2004 was it a fundraiser
and at that fundraiser there was a
comedian who got up his name was glenn
frey
and he was actually making jokes while
wearing blackface right he's actually
darkened his face and he was wearing a
freight wig
and tom hanks was cool with that okay
the controversy lasted about five
minutes
because tom hank said listen that never
should have happened it was
inappropriate
i don't know what was going on there i
understand people were offended and
everybody said right tom hanks isn't a
racist we know he didn't mean to mock
black people we know that he's not
interested
in taking in in somehow hurting black
people and everybody got on with their
lives
but because we are interested right now
and what can we pin people to the wall
over that makes for the worst available
country the worst version of ourselves
and that has to stop whether we're
talking about
megyn kelly or whether we're talking
about president trump or whether we're
talking about
the the attempt to nail people on the
other side of the aisle
in in reverse okay i'm going to talk a
little bit more about this plus i want
to talk about the latest on the caravan
issue in just a second plus there's some
breaking news
on the return address of the suspicious
packages
which is kind of weird okay we'll get to
that in just a second first
let's talk about your second amendment
rights again because your second
amendment rights are crucial and what
that means is that you need a weapon
that is going to function the way it's
supposed to function
bravo company manufacturing was started
in a garage by a marine vet
more than two decades ago to build a
professional-grade product that meets
combat standards
bcm believes the same level of
protection should be available to every
american regardless of whether they're a
private citizen
or a professional bcm is not a sporting
arms company well that makes sense
because the second amendment was not
about
shooting for fun okay they design
engineer they manufacture life-saving
equipment they assume each rifle leaving
their shop will be used in a life or
death situation
by a responsible citizen a law
enforcement officer or a soldier
overseas each component of a bcm rifle
is hand-assembled and tested by
americans to a life-saving standard
bcm feels a moral responsibility as
americans to provide tools that will not
fail the user
when they're not just looking down the
sites at a paper target but somebody
coming to actually hurt them
to learn more about bravo company
manufacturing head on over to
bravocompanymfg.com
you can discover more about their
products special offers upcoming news
that's bravocompanymfg.com
if you need more convincing go check out
more information about them at
youtube.com
bravo company usa again it's
bravocompanymfg.com
they're wonderful folks i mean the
people who found it are actual
veterans and they're ensuring that you
stay safe it's pretty
it's a pretty great company go check it
out bravocompanymfg.com okay i want to
give you an update
on this bomb situation in just one
second first you're going to have to go
subscribe at dailywire.com for 9.99 a
month you can get the rest of this show
live the rest of andrew clavin's show
live the rest of michael knowles is
awful show live
you get all of those well all of those
great things from one terrible thing you
get all of them
for 99 a month and when you spend 99 a
year you also get this the greatest at
all beverage vessels behold
behold its glory feast your eyes upon it
leftist tears hot
or cold tumbler making lives better
every day raising your level of
spirituality and virtue
one sip at a time that's what the
leftist tears hot or cold
tumbler does go check it out right now
also when you subscribe over youtube or
itunes
you get to see our sunday special
because it arrives in your feed
every single sunday and this week's
stars scott adams you know scott adams
he's the dilbert guy but he also
happens to be the great trump decoder
and we talked with him for a full hour
for the full hour
so here's what it sounds like hi i'm
scott adams
you can see me on the ben shapiro show
sunday special
where i'll be talking about my book win
bigly and persuasion
and president trump and are we in a
simulation all kinds of fun stuff
it did get pretty wild so you're going
to want to listen to that one go check
it out right now
we are the largest fastest growing
conservative podcast in the nation
[Music]
okay so the the update with regard to
these bombs that there's a return
address that was put on the labels to
debbie wasserman schultz's office that
doesn't mean that
debbie wasserman schultz is actually
sending these bombs it means that
somebody is probably trolling by doing
exactly that okay so i want to talk a
little bit
about a little bit more about you know
where we are as a society and how we how
we cure
all of this again we need to start with
the premise that the people that we are
talking about generally do not have
harm in mind that their goal is not to
destroy us in any way
if we figure that then we can have
normal elections
yes fraught heated elections but we're
not going to be trying to kill each
other
because we can assume that most people
in the united states grew up in the same
va
with the same value system we did and
they did i mean the reality is that we
all grew up in the same milieu
our values are not all that different
even the most right-wing members of the
united states and the most left-wing
members of the united states
theoretically agree on certain basic
values like freedom of speech
and treating each other compassionately
and decently why because we all grew up
in the same society
when you grow up in the same society you
share a certain level of baseline values
now i think that's splitting i think
that's one of the problems with the
country but one of the ways that that
split is exacerbated
is by simply assuming that political
disagreement reflects underlying
character differences
okay now speaking of political
disagreement and
you know the polarization of our
politics that social fabric those common
values i say
are being split and you're seeing it in
in some of these democratic
campaigns one of those campaigns is from
stacy adams she's the georgia
gubernatorial candidate for the
democrats
and she was caught on tape talking about
free markets here's what she had to say
and i am sick and tired of hearing about
the free market being the solution
to this problem because i've never seen
the free market write a prescription in
rural georgia
i mean never seen a free market show up
to give someone metformin
so they can have a little bit of control
of their diabetes before it turns into
an amputation of their stacy abrams if
you can't hear her she's saying that the
free market
has never solved any problems in the
medical field which is obviously untrue
these are baseline root issues in
american politics so i think stacey
abrams is there for lacking in character
no i don't
i think she's just wrong i think she's
wrong and she doesn't know enough about
economics
and she's misinterpreting the economics
that she does know but
is she a bad person i don't know stacey
abrams probably not
even though you know there's tape of her
i believe now burning a flag back in
college so i guess we're now
ripping directly from scripts written by
aaron sorkin like we're actually just
going to do the american president all
over again
with stacey abrams i've noticed this
weird trend in the news the last couple
of days like there was there was a
luftwaffe
plane that landed on the 101 north okay
like
not that far from where we filmed this
and
all i can say is thank god for the raf
because the royal air force really took
care of business making sure the
luftwaffe and
so the man in the high castle is coming
true that's exciting
and apparently stacey abrams is directly
from
the american president and then there
was a story that i saw today about a guy
who looks exactly like david schwimmer
robbing a liquor store and robbing it of
beer
so ross from friends has been cut loose
and president trump is the president
donald trump is the president
of the united states so you know scott
scott adams is a guy who says we may be
living in a simulation i'm starting to
maybe believe that we are just living
inside a weird weird weird script
but in any case the the the
the divisions that that are growing in
the country
those need to be rectified but they
cannot be rectified in any serious way
unless we start
unless we stop attributing the worst
available motives to everybody
and that holds true even with regard to
some of these stupidities like
the worship for beta or which is foolish
but
i don't think it's coming from a place
of people who are bad i think it's just
coming from a place of people who
fall in love with politicians in the
dumbest possible way okay now speaking
of attributing bad motives
let's talk about the latest on the
caravan so the illegal immigrant caravan
continues to move up through mexico
they're about a thousand miles from the
border right now probably less
they're apparently ten thousand people
who are walking toward the border
the folks who are in that caravan as i
have said i think many of them
are looking for a better life they're
looking to come into the united states
that doesn't mean that the united states
has to admit
all of those people or any of those
people the united states gets to pick
and choose who we decide to admit
to the country and yet this is cast as a
great moral issue that if you believe
that america should secure its border
this means that you are racist and nasty
and bigoted and terrible and if you
believe that people should be admitted
to the country
because they need a better place to live
then this is because you don't care
about america's interests
the truth is that people who believe in
free flow of immigration
even free flow of illegal immigration
generally they believe that that makes
the country better because
on a moral level we have to uphold
certain charitable instincts
i disagree with that assessment but
that's where that's coming from
and for people who say we have to secure
our border that is also coming from a
good place it's coming from the idea
that
any country that wishes to preserve its
strength so that it can help other
people
has to have limits on who gets to enter
the country so again
there's a way to explain this debate in
which we examine everybody's best
motives
it's it's hard to do that in a polarized
political environment it's hard to do
that in a polarized political
environment
so president trump uh he uh he had said
about this illegal immigrant caravan
that there were random middle easterners
in the middle of it and criminals in the
middle of it
it turns out there may be criminals i'd
be shocked if there are not criminals in
the middle of it people have been
convicted of crimes and deported who are
now trying to come back in
there's no evidence of of random middle
easterners and he was asked about it
here was his
statement in response
there's no proof of anything there's no
proof of anything
uh but they could very well be okay
there could very well be is not a good
answer to
an accusation that you made about people
who are trying to come into the united
states again that is a political tactic
by the president
in order to get people to talk about the
incipient criminality of the folks who
are in that march
but it is one it's another way of
polarizing politics this is why i've
said both right and left are responsible
for what's happening
right now in the country i'm not going
to pretend that this exists only on one
side for my own political purposes i
just don't think that's honest
at the same time you see the response to
that which is jorge ramos
who says there are no middle eastern
easterners in this caravan and tucker's
like
um tucker carlson who's interviewing him
he's like well
there are still criminals in that
caravan and jorge ramos says
right but they're no middle easterners
it's like well now you're deliberately
missing the point
in order to castigate the other side is
racist first of all
i spent two days with these refugees and
i have not seen
a single person from the middle east
that's a lie
and i think tucker you have you have to
tell the truth to your audience
and you don't have you have to make sure
that
people are not lying about this caravan
because the people from the middle east
are not part of this
let me just limit this stupidity on one
side drives stupidity on the other one
the president says they're middle
easterners without evidence who are part
of the caravan
and the left says well there are no
middle easterners that means the
caravan's good
this is not the central argument in any
way shape or form obviously
the central argument about the caravan
is whether the united states ought to
have borders that are protected
or whether the united states is
obligated by morality and decency and
international law to let people freely
cross the border
making that latter case is tom perez
who's the head of the dnc and this gets
down to the root of the issue and this
is where americans really should be
deciding the issue not on the basis of
stupidities about middle easterners and
a caravan but on the basis of
what are the values we wish to uphold as
a country and how do we protect the
country best here's tom perez giving the
wrong answer to jake tapper on cnn
we are a nation of laws and the laws
that are on the books
deal with issues of refugee and asylum
status
and those are the laws that have always
applied
it's a humanitarian uh issue of
significance
and our laws require that people be
treated with dignity and given that
process
okay well they are given that process
they can go to any checkpoint that they
wish to go to and they can apply for
asylum in the united states
again the implication by tom perez here
a little bit is that folks on the other
side
don't want to treat people who are
trying to cross the border illegally
with dignity
that is inherently untrue so in essence
the theme of today's show and what
should be the theme of our politics is
if we want to have serious discussions
with folks on the other side
we have to cut out the idea that they
are inherently bad evil folks who are
manifesting that bad and that evil
in ways designed to destroy the country
if we actually believe that then we are
five minutes from civil war if we
actually believe that the other side is
hitler then we are justified in trying
to kill hitler
so all this has to stop all this has to
stop and if we don't stop it then things
are going to get a lot worse
before they get any better okay time for
some things i like and then some things
that i hate and then we'll do a psalm a
bit of an uplifting song so
things i like today i was listening to
some of my favorite music
last night uh i've recommended the music
of ray von williams before
one of the great british composers he he
wrote
probably my favorite piece of music ever
fantasia on a theme by thomas talas
which i've
recommended on the show before he also
wrote a fantasia on greensleeves that is
just fantastic
he wrote a beautiful piece for violin
called the lark ascending uh it's it's a
difficult piece i mean
i play it a little bit but it's a
difficult piece this is a recording with
iona brown on violin with neville
mariner in the academy of st martin in
the fields
it's it's a beautiful piece and very
effective
and as a lifelong violinist i don't
brown plays the hell out of the violin
she's just terrific
so go check out this recording it's
quite beautiful it's on a cd with all of
the pieces i just mentioned
uh cd i know it's a thing colton
colton's cd it used to have music on it
it was like a disc and you put in a
machine it spun
really fast and then it would play music
for you it was kind of cool um
i kind of miss it although it used to
take up too much room in my house uh
okay time
for a couple of things that i hate
the thing i hate number one goes to the
essence of the show today
this is a tweet from bruce bartlett who
is a member of the political left here's
what he tweeted
key differences between donald trump and
adolf hitler hitler served honorably in
the military trump didn't
hitler was faithful to his wife trump
cheated on all his wives
hitler wrote a book trumps were all
ghostwritten praising hitler to own the
cons
that's uh an interesting angle an
interesting angle
first off adolf hitler also killed
six million people in a genocide and 11
million people
total in in mass murders
leaving aside the number of people who
died overall in world war ii so there
was that that was kind of a key
distinction
also hitler had a mustache um but i mean
if we're just gonna talk about like
differences i wouldn't
i love this i love when he says hitler
was faithful to his wife he was married
to eva braun for 24 hours before they
killed themselves so i mean this is just
also basically
ignorance of history he literally
married her and then they committed
suicide so there was that
um also i love this hitler wrote a book
that book was called mineconf it wasn't
a good book
there were some problems with that book
bruce trumps were all ghost written
you know who else had his books ghosts
written for him john f kennedy
so if you're going to do hitler wrote a
book trump's world ghost written
man oh man yeah i'm gonna go with this
is kind of crazy
okay other things that i hate so the pod
save america bros
who as i've said before i think that
they do a good job at what they do i
think they're wrong about virtually
everything but they're very talented at
what they do
the folks over at crooked media they
were hosted on stephen colbert again i
think it's like the fourth or the fifth
time they've been on stephen colbert's
show
for all those folks who pretend that
late night comedy is not politically
influenced or biased you're insane
okay i will give you a guess as to how
many times this is not about me
but it is about me let me let me hazard
a guess how many times have i
ever been invited on a late night comedy
show ever
the answer is zero i've never ever been
invited on any late night comedy show
the only comedy show i've ever been
invited on was trevor noah
and i insisted that if i were going to
do an interview with trevor noah it had
to be live in front of the audience i
was not going to be taped and then cut
apart the way they did to jonah goldberg
when jonah was on trevor noah's show i
was not going to do that so
but the pod save america bros are on
with stephen colbert specifically
because colbert is a far leftist and
what makes them newsworthy i'm not sure
other than i mean they've got to show on
hbo we had a show on fox
whatever here is stephen colbert with
the positive america bros basically
doing get out the vote for democrats
how many times are we going to do this
all right it doesn't matter what the
early votes look like it doesn't matter
what the polls look like we can lose
everything
we lost everything two years ago we
could lose everything again
oh my god okay and quick correction i
was on bill maher so good for bill maher
good for bill maher that was the one
that was one example of a show i was
actually invited on and that i went on
because it was
live but stephen colbert is uh not on
pay cable
stephen colbert is is nightly so
the the bias in the media is a very very
real thing okay time for a quick solemn
so after all of that negativity it's
time for a little bit of uplift
so psalm 10 we've been going through a
psalm a week more or less we've been
missing some weeks
but one of the things that i love about
the psalms and the reason that they
carry over time the reason that they've
been crucial to
religious people's understanding of god
for thousands of years is because the
psalms don't sugarcoat things
they really don't you know for all the
people who believe that religious people
think
that everything is hunky-dory that we're
living in this kind of fantasy world
where everything is great nothing bad
ever happens
all you have to do is read the anguish
that is implicit in the psalms and you
know
that king david and king solomon and all
the folks who are writing the psalms
that the these psalms are deeply in tune
with
human anguish and need right psalm 10 is
an example of this starts
why lords you stand far off why do you
hide yourselves in times of trouble
it's a pretty harsh indictment of god
right where where are you when things
are rough
and we all feel like that religious
people feel like that that is the
challenge of faith
this again i hate this kind of ned
flanders approach by the secular left to
religion
that everybody who's religious is
actually just everything's hunky-dory
everything's great
that's not how religious people feel
about things at all this is why it's so
weird to folks who are religious when
non-religious people say to them well
you know how can there be a god
when bad things happen in the world it's
like oh you're the first person who
thought of
the question of theodicy you're the
first person in history who thought of
that question
now that you've said that bad things
happen to children i guess you've
defeated me
this is legitimately an argument made by
people who are secular all the time well
you know if god is good then why do bad
things happen
i don't know we have thousands of years
of theology discussing this exact issue
and the final answer is basically that
you aren't god that's basically the
answer
and that's not always a comforting
answer but it is a true answer
and it's a reality-based answer psalm 10
says in his arrogance the wicked man
hunts down the weak who are caught in
the schemes he devises
he boasts about the cravings of his
heart he blesses the greedy and reviles
the lord
in his pride the wicked man does not
seek him in all his thoughts there is no
room for god it's interesting how
wicked folks are characterized not just
as people who do other people harm you
know hunting down the weak
but also they're characterized as folks
who don't spend any time thinking about
god and i think those two things
are related it doesn't mean every
atheist person is is bad
not by a long shot i think i know a lot
of wonderful atheist moral folks
doesn't mean every religious person is
good a lot of horrible horrible
religious people
but it does mean that people who
genuinely are wicked including religious
people spend very little time thinking
about higher morality or what is
demanded of them by their god
instead they're spending a lot of time
thinking about what they want his ways
are always prosperous your laws are
rejected by him
he sneers at all his enemies he says to
himself nothing will ever shake me he
swears
no one will ever do me harm this is the
wicked man obviously
you know king david you know suffering
from the from
king david let a pretty rough life right
and there's a guy who was being chased
from place to place by king saul
uh he was constantly in threat of murder
his kingdom broke down
over succession disputes between his own
children several of whom
died in the process of him maintaining
his kingdom
when you when you talk to a religious
person if you're secular even if you're
even if you're not religious
you should recognize that religious
people do think about the serious
problems of life on a daily basis
their answer may be different than yours
i think it's a more inspiring answer
than the secular answer and i think it's
also a truer answer than the secular
answer the secular answer is basically
bleep happens the religious answer is
bleep happens but that's because god is
in charge
and we don't understand god and i think
that's a fairer answer to to the
question
than simply random chance okay we will
be back here tomorrow
with all of the latest i'm ben shapiro
this is the ben shapiro show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is produced by
senja villarreal executive producer
jeremy boring senior producer jonathan
haye our supervising producer is mathis
glover and our technical producer is
austin stevens
edited by alex ingaro audio is mixed by
mike caromina hair and makeup is by
jessua alvera the ben shapiro show is a
daily wire forward publishing production
copyright forward publishing 2018